[Musik]
hallo herr zirkuswelt ich habe frische
erdbeeren von unseren bauern klaus
bekommen auf reilingen und dann habe ich
mir gedacht wag ich doch mal wieder eine
leckere tat und es wurde diese
wunderschöne tat daraus ich habe mir
nämlich eine tat gemacht mit einem moped
boden unten ist eine richtig schöne
erdbeer creme eine marmelade darüber
eine quarkcreme und die wird dann hübsch
dekoriert und ich finde so eine tat die
schmeckt einfach sommerlich die schmeckt
frisch und fruchtig und nicht so schwer
perfekt für die warmen tage das erste
was ihr dafür zubereiten müsst ist
praktisch der mürbeteig und dann zeige
ich euch mal kurz die zutaten für den
mürbeteig verwende ich 70 gramm zucker
140 gramm kalte butter 210 gramm mehl
weizen oder dinkel ein eigelb etwas
wandel extrakt und eine prise salz für
den mürbeteig gibt jetzt einfach die
kalte butter und zucker in eine große
schüssel entweder mit der hand verkneten
mit dem handrührgerät oder einfach mit
der küchenmaschine aber bei mürbeteig
immer schön darauf achten dass die
zutaten kalt sind er soll nämlich nicht
warm und weich werden sondern immer
schön kalt bleiben damit das schöne
möbel wird
[Musik]
sobald sich alles verbunden hat gebe ich
jetzt noch das mehl dazu
auch ein
extrakt und
etwas
[Musik]
sieht super aus und
damit der teig so ein bisschen schön
zusammen findet dich immer noch kurz mit
der hand zusammen
was ist schon richtig gut
doch eigentlich nur noch mehr sorgen
zusammendrücken
[Musik]
das reicht auch schon und dann kommt er
direkt in den kühlschrank natürlich
abgedeckt für etwa eine stunde zurück
denn gerne immer so ein bisschen flach
kühl doch schneller ab und dann kann ich
mich später gleich um die etwa masse
gewinnen
nach der kür zeit nehmt jetzt den teig
raus und knetet ihnen so ein bisschen
durch dass er einfach geschmeidig wird
und dann reiste auch gleich nicht beim
aufrollen falls doch
einfach nur so ein bisschen was spürt
dann finde ich auch dass er dann
geschmeidig genug ist zum ausrollen und
am besten nehmt ihr euch eine silikon
matte
denn da braucht man nicht so viel mehl
den mail machst den dreck einfach sehr
trocken
wo wir noch trockenes wetter hat auch
brüchig
ok
jetzt gleich eine tat form dafür mit
hebe boden und zwar sind die perforiert
das heißt ihm viele kleine löcher und
dadurch kommt ebenso eine ganz tolle
kruste zustande das packt gleichmäßig
durch und die werde ich jetzt einfach
kurz vorher einfetten
mit bagdad
und wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr gern noch
gehobelte mandeln am boden verstreut
und jetzt wollt ihr den teig ein
bisschen größer als die form aus die hat
jetzt 25 zentimeter im durchmesser dann
mache ich so ungefähr 30 und jetzt könnt
ihr hier gern aus stab nehmen mit 5 mm
abstand ring da wird auch schon
gleichmäßig
wurde probiert halt einfach schön
immer noch ein bisschen mehr
ich gehe dann immer noch gerne mit so
einer palette einmal drunter und
verteilt sich es mir auch ganz gut
[Musik]
und dann hier schön auf rollen und in
die form legen
[Musik]
drückt ihr das hier am rand so ein
bisschen fest
und könnte den überrest einfach so ein
bisserl wegschneiden am besten mit einer
palette schön von innen nach außen
streichen
[Musik]
aus dem kleinen rest ihr bereite ich
gleich noch kekse zu die tat vom waren
das jetzt aber noch mal kurz ins
gefrierfach damit die butter noch mal
richtig schön kalt wird und dann kann
sie im ofen gebacken werden ich muss
auch sagen auf sprint backen verzichte
ich tatsächlich blind backen heißt
nämlich man legt jetzt ein backpapier
ein und beschwört den teig dann mit
hülsenfrüchten zb linsen oder bohnen es
gibt auch bakbone in extra dafür dann
bleibt der teig nämlich auch schön unten
was wir auch machen könnt ihr könnt das
ganze auch ein stechen aber ich muss
sagen ich beobachte dass immer kurz im
ofen und wenn ich sehe ist steigt ein
bisschen nach oben dann stehe ich
einfach kurz rein ansonsten lasse ich so
denn meistens hebt sich damit gar nicht
da bleibt immer schön flach wenn er
vorher eben für etwa 15 minuten ein
gefahndet
[Musik]
da könnte jetzt einfach die rolle nehmen
und kleine stückchen formen dann kleine
kugeln rollen
sie könnte jetzt so ganz leicht mit mehl
bestäuben
die tan offen blech setzen und mit einem
keks stempel eindrücken
den könnte jetzt vorher entweder in mehl
tauchen oder zum beispiel ein bisschen
cacau dann habt ihr auch direkt ein
schönes muster
[Musik]
leonard hierbei kam jürgen
heine
und goethe slowly
leonard jörg
die tat es im ofen hier habe ich die
zutaten für die erdbeermarmelade dafür
verwende ich einziger fünf kilo
erdbeeren stellt sogar den drei zu eins
also davon ein päckchen 500 gramm etwas
zitronensaft und mangel extrakt ja das
geht jetzt ganz einfach ich brauche
natürlich nicht die komplette
erdbeermarmelade aber bei etwa
beziehungsweise bei gelierzucker ist es
schon so wenn man das päckchen öffnet
muss man eigentlich ganze päckchen
benutzen denn der schulpartner drin also
dass schon die mittel verteilt sich
manchmal nicht ganz so gut und so kann
man einfach sichergehen dass eben alles
land darin landet das heißt ihr könnt
einfach gleich schöne art bar marmelade
machen und falls ihr doch keine admin
kochen wollte keine erdbeermarmelade
dann können sie auch ganz einfach etwa
marmelade benutzen aber ich habe hier
der trend vom waldlauf und habe da schon
das grüne entfernt und deswegen gibt es
eine leckere erdbeermarmelade
[Musik]
dann ordentlich vanille extrakt und dann
verstand dass sie mit der hacke und
können sie dann aufhören so wie es eben
auch auf der verpackung steht und ob
neben der groß genug ist ja das spiel
nämlich ordentlich
[Musik]
super aus
marmelade kocht auch und ich werde hier
einfach nur den rand so ein bisschen mit
einem glas nochmal so entlang drücken
dann ist richtig schön
[Musik]
den was jetzt abkühlen kümmere mich
weiter um die marmelade gekocht wir noch
zwei minuten und dann passiere ich sie
einfach durch die flotte lotte oder das
fleißige lieschen und fühlen sie dann in
schraubgläser
abgehört
[Musik]
jetzt ist die marmelade fertig passiert
ich habe es jetzt nochmal schön
aufkochen lassen
perfekt
und eine schöpfkelle voll gebe ich jetzt
einfach hier direkt auf den fast
abgekühlten boden und den rest für dich
in marmeladengläsern ab denn ein teil
davon werde ich dann auch noch benutzen
für meine creme später aber wie gesagt
ein teil kommt jetzt hier rein und das
ist dann wie so eine art schutzschicht
der mittdreißiger bisschen da wird eine
schöne schöne erdbeermarmelade
[Musik]
für die creme verwende ich 250 quark 200
gramm einer abgekühlten erdbeermarmelade
400 gramm schlagsahne und seiner
partnerstadt schlagen
jetzt ihr um die master langem eine
creme und zwar verriet jetzt einfach den
quark mit der erdbeer marmelade
das wäre jetzt lecker fruchtig locker
deswegen auch quark das ist einfach so
eine schöne sommerliche tat wird die
marmelade rein kurz berühren dann die
sahne dazu gießen und mit seiner bad
steif schlagen dass es meine creme
[Musik]
da damit jetzt hier meine schöne
abgekühlte tat jeweils auch im
kühlschrank da kommt jetzt die creme
trafen und wird schon verstrichen
[Musik]
es ist mir bis auf die suche gehen denn
die großen event für die creme und für
die marmelade waren ja von meinem bauern
klaus und die kleinen etwa die sind von
hier aus meinem garten ist nämlich
walderdbeeren und die wachsen hier so
schön gut mal richtig schöne bodendecker
sind es
[Musik]
er macht uns nass
ich habe geschrieben meiner kamera
[Musik]
jetzt der schönste teil die tat wird
herausgelöst und dekoriert
mit hebel boden gut und wenn die schon
gebacken ist dann kommt sie auch
wirklich richtig schön raus
und dann
legte sie vorsichtig ab da ist es noch
der boden darunter am besten mit einer
palette darunter gehen
kurz ablösen
jetzt immer vorsichtig sein denn so eine
tat ist richtig rutschig das heißt wenn
ihr die später transportiert nicht den
da machen sondern am besten immer mit
den daumen substituieren oder ihre
streiche kriegen
und dann nehme ich jetzt meine schönen
wald aus dem garten noch ein paar große
erdbeer bisschen erdbeer früchte
knuspern müsli und dekor ist schön und
hier noch ein tipp von mir falls ihr
erdmann aufschneidet und sie auf der
oberfläche dekoriert könnt ihr es immer
ganz gut mit dem tortenguss zum sprühen
einfach einsprühen das ist praktisch aka
aka schon bereits vor gemischt oder ihre
pinsel sehr einfach ganze mit einer
marmelade damit sie einfach nicht
austrocknen
[Musik]
dabei
das gefällt mir richtig gut
jetzt probiert
ich habe jetzt zwei gaben ein tag stück
und eine
super ich freue mich riesig auf das
sieht so klasse auf der tischspur der
ich hoffe die schmeckt jetzt aber bin
eigentlich gut hat ehrlich mit den
zutaten übelste gerne das gar nicht
nicht schwer glaubt bauer klaus wer
stolzer torte sehen würde diesmal haben
wir müssen ein stück bringen auf jeden
fall ruin moto2 dazu ja immer die cigna
pop art macht aus dem buch hat bringt
dem hause stückgut sei dann darfst du
mal probieren ja
es tut mir ständig
[Gelächter]
total.com das
richtig gut
klaus
kinski sally
los geht's dir gut
du ich habe aus deiner erdbeere habe ich
eine erdbeertorte gemacht bist du daheim
dorf der murat der bringt er jetzt heute
vorbei zum probieren
ich gucke mal ob es kommen kann
ein traktor und repariere ok ja
alles klar okay bis gleich
original wir bringen mit den
planerischen spricht dialekt habe aber
wie kommt man
also super lecker ich finde aussagen
probiert das rezept gerne mal aus das
rezept findet ihr wie immer auch salehs
blog.de unser blog ist übrigens seit
kurzem richtig schön neu gestaltet die
suche ist besser die aufteilung die
gestaltung da haben sich unsere mädels
und jungs echt ganz viel mühe gegeben
schaut da gern vorbei die app wird
komplett erneuert auch die shop seite
ist erneut als bekommt alles von junges
neues frisches design das ist richtig
schön ja tolle bilder tolle menschen
hier ich bin richtig glücklich und jetzt
nochmal bleiben und dann klaus glücklich
macht bis zum nächsten mal
[Applaus]
[Musik]